we begin with this story today the
western u.s dealing with a crippling
drought and lake mead has been suffering
for quite some time now
but today another rough milestone the
lake today expected to drop
to its lowest level since it began
filling in the 1930s
the u.s bureau of reclamation says the
lake level will
likely keep falling until november and
that will affect
everything from recreation to hydropower
nevada and arizona are already bracing
for less water from the colorado river
starting
next year but the continued drop in
water level really impacts the entire
western u.s
especially for farmers so next year
we're going to get about 25 percent less
water means we're going to have to
follow or not plant
25 percent of our land many farmers are
rushing to dig wells to tap into ground
water
governor steve sisolak is also taking
steps to stay water here in our state
he did sign a bill that gets rid of
non-functional turf
that is grass that doesn't get used in
places like sidewalks and parking lots
we can all do our part though now to
save water easy things turn off the tap
water when you're not using it
take shorter showers things like that
it's important we all do our part when
we can